[Music]
2021 was basically the best year ever
for the housing market but
real estate experts are expecting things
to slow down in 2022 at least in terms
of prices i'm gonna explain why that is
and what that means for the overall real
estate market this year now even if you
don't own
property values drive rental prices snow
owners this affects you too
let's get into it
last year the median sales price for a
typical u.s home rose to a record high
and housing prices are expected to have
risen by around 16 percent according to
the federal housing finance agency that
would also be a record high i've read
through a couple market outlooks and the
projections aren't looking quite as hot
for 2022. the mortgage bankers
association predicts that prices will
rise by just five percent this year and
redfin they think that prices are going
to gain just three percent now remember
that's compared to 16 price appreciation
for 2021. here are three major reasons
prices could cool down in 2022
increased supply
i was talking with mike fratt and tony
he's the chief economist for the
mortgage bankers association and he's
expecting more new home construction
this year a lot more home building means
a lot more homes in the market and as a
result he's expecting to see a lot more
people list their homes for sale in 2022
in his words mike says this is good news
for the many would-be buyers who are
currently priced out or delaying
decisions
the federal reserve is planning to raise
u.s interest rates the fed is projecting
three interest rate hikes this year the
first one could come as soon as march at
least that's what the market is
predicting deutsche bank thinks it could
be as many as four rate hikes that
matters because as interest rates rise
mortgage rates rise and higher mortgage
rates mean higher monthly home costs
those could really make some buyers
reconsider especially with prices
already so high inflation is slowing
down at least that's what economists are
predicting as the cost of building
materials wages and other housing inputs
rise more slowly the average home price
should calm down as well mba predicts
four percent inflation this year well
below 2021 space which saw inflation
rise the highest rate in almost 40 years
so when you put it all together
all of these factors should slow down
the crazy price appreciation we saw last
year but that doesn't mean that you can
expect to see big discounts in the
market for buyers this means you can
take a breath when searching for a home
there's likely to be more options for
sellers
expect more competition as folks who
have been waiting around to list their
homes finally put that for sale sign up
in their yards mba expects housing
prices to increase month to month but
because of market volatility the
organization sees housing prices in the
fourth quarter of 2022
sitting right around where they were in
the fourth quarter of 2021.
if you enjoyed this video hit the like
button and if you're interested in
markets and want to watch and learn more
subscribe to this channel to keep up
with my latest as houston's own maxo
cream reminds us i left the hood they
called me fake but ain't ish realer than
real estate
that's it for now i'll see you next time
[Music]